let's say that you wanted to write some
software that would enable people to see
with their ears to make initial
experiments easier you might start by
treating incoming images with a low
resolution maybe 256x 256 pixels and to
make my own animation efforts easier
let's represent one of these images with
a square grid each cell corresponding
with a pixel one approach to this sound
to sight software would be to find a
nice way to associate each one of those
pixels with a unique frequency value
then when that pixel is brighter the
frequency associated with it would be
played louder and if the pixel were
darker the frequency would be quiet
listening to all of the pixels all at
once would then sound like a bunch of
frequencies overlaid on top of one
another with dominant frequencies
corresponding to The Brighter regions of
the image sounding like some cacophonous
mess until your brain learns to make
sense out of the information that it
contains